[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi
I'm Wayne Piekarski
for "The Developer Show."
And this is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The latest Android
Emulator release
can now run Excite 6-based
Android virtual devices
on computers that
use AMD processors.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for getting started
instructions and the download
link.
The TensorFlow
Object Detection API
is an open-source framework
built on top of TensorFlow
that makes it easy to construct,
train, and deploy object
detection models.
And we recently released
several additions to the API,
including support for
accelerated training of object
detection models via cloud TPUs,
improving the mobile deployment
process, and several new model
architecture definitions.
A link to the new
tutorial is on the post.
Over 130 Googlers attended the
35th International Conference
on Machine Learning last week
to present publications and host
workshops.
You can learn more about
the research we presented
and download the papers
with the links on this post.
Jib is an open source Java
containerizer from Google
that lets you build
containers using the Java
tools that you know.
It's fast, simple, and
handles all the steps
of packaging your application
into a container image.
Head on over to the post for
more details and examples
on Maven and Gradle.
And the Los Angeles Google
Cloud Platform region
is now officially
open for business.
You can now store data and build
highly available performant
applications in
Southern California.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Wayne Piekarski for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: I'll throw
out some emotion.
Excited.
Shocked.